léon irrite de la maison paternelle
malgré les souvenirs les eaux décide de
vendre la maison après l'avoir inspectée
une dame achète sa mère mais dix ans
plus tard les eaux reçoit une mise en
demeure de l'acheteur et lui explique
qu'à la suite d'une infiltration 12 mois
dernier elle a découvert que les
fondations des maisons sont assises sur
que l'aspirine
selon elle il s'agit un vice caché pour
lequel elle demande un dédommagement
l'est où il y aurait tout de ces
problèmes de fondation nous avons un nul
10 à 10 ans peut-il être tenu
responsable
la réponse est oui le point civil oblige
le vendeur à garantir que la maison
qu'il rend est exempt de vice caché
l'acheteur pourrait donc poursuivre les
au lait ou aurait-il pu éviter une telle
mésaventure
oui il est possible de se libérer de
cette obligation
il aurait pu ajouter une clause dans le
contrat de vente indiquant que la maison
était vendu sans garantie légale ou
risques et périls de l'acheteur vain mot
de l'histoire
si vous oubliez votre ancienne maison
elle ne vous oublie pas